without water from the colorado river
modern las vegas couldn't exist our
community gets about 90 percent of its
water from the river but after two
decades of drought and climate change
the river is in serious trouble the 8
news now i-team's george knapp traveled
to the source of our water supply to
find out what the experts are predicting
[Music]
the the critical time frame is pretty
much about now to
uh
april late april so here's the process
that we typically go through brian
dominocos was educated to be an engineer
but you wouldn't be wrong if you called
him a professional snowman 52.00 he's a
supervisor for the colorado snow survey
a crucial program carried out by a
little-known federal agency the natural
resources conservation service they
monitor and measure snowfall in the
rockies it's that maximum snowpack that
gives us the best idea of how much snow
we're going to have to actually run off
into the streams and then we'll of
course be our water supply for
colorado
new mexico arizona nevada
stumbling along atop snowshoes we've
crawled up beyond the 11 000 foot level
of the rockies a stone's throw from the
continental divide to check out one of
the more than 100 monitoring sites
called snotels data from the snotel's
sensors gets sent out to the world
hourly
the team carries out tests to measure
the depth of the snowpack but more
importantly its weight the weight is
what gives them an idea of how much of
the snow will eventually melt and
trickle its way down to the colorado
river ninety percent of the water in the
river comes from rain and snow that fall
on the western side of the rockies
ninety percent is also the number for
how much of las vegas water supply comes
from the colorado which is often
described as the most endangered river
in north america everything that happens
in las vegas all growth and economic
activity is dependent on the river we
know that uh right now at this site
snowpack is 83 of normal 83 of normal
may not sound so bad but it comes after
more than two decades of extended
drought in the west temperatures have
climbed the hotter drier climate means
the west is caught in a vicious cycle
more wildfires more dust storms less
rain and snow particulates that fall
atop the snow affect how and when it
melts and because the soil is drier much
of the snow melt is absorbed and never
makes it down to the river the result is
easy to see lakes mead and powell are at
historic lows the lower colorado river
states have already enacted cuts to the
amount of water they can take from the
river and more cuts are likely and this
year has been a little bit extreme the
snow survey team doesn't make climate
predictions that job falls to other
federal and state agencies but 2022 is
already proven to be a puzzler in
january it looked like the snowpack
would be at or near the historic average
but snowfall in february sort of fell
off a cliff is there still a possibility
of enough snow to get back to normal
this year the experts say it's possible
but unlikely
the snow monitors hope that as las vegas
frolic in pools and water their lawns
they appreciate how precious this
resource is
creating a general awareness across the
entire united states would really help
boost uh and give a better understanding
of how important it is and why
monitoring it and being conservative
with the water that we have with the
snowpack that we have is such an
important part of life out here george
knapp 8 news now